ces bobines ont disparu pendant des
années personne ne pensait que le second
Hitler avait une passion
secrète les films de sa collection privé
le montre dans son rôle
favori au sommet de sa puissance au
milieu de la foule en
liè hermaning reçu en Autriche
il a longtemps été le confident le plus
proche
[Musique]
d'Hitler en tant que commandant en chef
de La l ging a créé une arme
puissante Hitler et ging deux carrières
étroit
li quels sont les points communs entre
leurs deux
parcours que révèl ces film sur le
personnage le plus exubérant du National
Socialisme
CHF est une commune idylique entourée de
lac et de forêt au nord de Berlin c'est
là que se trouvait l'imposante demeure
de
ging
carinal la demeure d'un homme qui disait
de lui-même je suis un homme de la
Renaissance j'aime la
splendeur il veut être le visage jovial
de la dictature mais hermaning maréchal
du 3è Reich était impliqué dans tout ce
dont le régime s'était rendu
responsable élimination des opposants
politiques crime par million guerre
mondiale
meurtrière carinal du nom de sa première
épouse est le symbole d'une brillante
carrière ce modeste pavillon de chasse
est devenu un grand DOM un manoir que le
fier Seigneur a filmé avec sa propre
caméra pendant la guerre alors que les
défaites s'accumulent et que les villes
allemandes tombent sous une pluie de
bomb c'est la qui se retire de plus en
plus souvent dans un monde privé loin de
la
[Musique]
réalité il regarde ce genre de film dans
son h
cinéma
ces images le distrait des populations
qui souffrent des bombardements des
pertes immenses de la LFT Vau des
millions de victimes de toutes ces
promesses non
[Musique]
tenues au moins nous avons bien vécu
pendant 12 ans dira-t-il plus
tard après la mort d'Hitler en 1945 ging
prisonnier de guerre est le plus haut
gradé des nazis encore en vie
il est emmené dans un camp pour criminel
de guerre allemand en attendant d'être
jugé devant un tribunal
allié même lors des procès de nberg il
ne reconnaîtra jamais sa
responsabilitéz-vous coupable ou non
coupable je plaide mon
coupable finalement il se condamne de
luime
[Musique]
poison ce fut la dernière étape
inattendue d'une incroyable
[Musique]
carrière Herman velm ging fils d'un
ancien fonctionnaire colonial grandit
dans le château d'un vieux chevalier de
Franconie au sud de l'Allemagne
il appartient à son parrain juif avec
lequel sa mère a une
[Musique]
liaison ging est considéré comme un
enfant difficile et sa mère prophétise
qu'il deviendra soit un homme influent
soit un grand
criminel pour comprendre mon frère dit
sa sœur Paula il faut se rendre au
château de weldenstein où il a passé une
jeunesse romantique à lire des romans et
à jouer au chevalier jour après
jour
dès son enfance ging se passionne pour
tous les sujets militaires s'il y a une
guerre ditil je ne manquerai pas de
faire honneur au nom de
[Musique]
ging pendant la Première Guerre mondiale
le jeune soldat combat pour la première
fois en
Alsace il est blessé et élabore de
nouveaux projet dans un hôpital
militaire
le souslieutenant ging Viso il veut
devenir pilote militaire et héros de
guerre on lui attribue l'abattage de 22
avions le Kaiser en personne lui décerne
la plus haute distinction prussienne
pour le
[Musique]
mérite en tant que dernier commandant du
célèbre escadron de chasseen il est
connu dans tout le
pays mais lorsque la défaite met fin à
cette incroyable carrière son monde
s'écroule après la guerre l'aviation
allemande est
démantelée maising veut continuer à
voler et pas en Suède pour devenir
pilote de
ligne un jour l'explorateur Eric von Ros
emmèneing dans son château à
rockstad
cette visite change sa
vie il rencontre Karine qui sera sa
première femme
elle quitte son mari et ses enfants pour
épouser un pilote de la Première Guerre
mondiale un scandale pour la société de
l'époque après la mort de Karine en 1931
ging préserve sa
mémoire il donne son nom à fait faire
des peintures d'elle et même une salle
sa
[Musique]
mémoire Ginga un penchant pour la
mythologie
[Musique]
nordique il bâti sa demeure à shorf
carinal ce nom évoque le valala l'eau de
la destinée aux guerriers qui sont morts
en se battant
vaillamment
plus tard ging fera transférer la dépuie
de sa femme de la Suède à
[Musique]
carinal peu après leur mariage en 1922
il s'installe à munique où le parti
national socialiste des travailleurs
allemands est en train de se faire un
nom face à Hitler pour la première fois
ging est complètement subjugué comme il
le dit lui-même Hitler nom commandant
dessa les troupes du parti et décare un
héros de guerre avec une médaille pour
le mérite une excellente
propagande lors d'un PCH à munique en
novembre 1923 Hitler tente de prendre le
pouvoir mais la police bavaroise ouvre
le feu sur les partisans d'Hitler devant
la f
d'nal ging est gravement blessé les
médecins lui donnent de la morphine pour
soulager la
douleur ainsi commence une longue
dépendance à la drogue
en 1924 Herman et Karin ging se rendent
à
Venise sur ordre d'Hitler qui est en
prisoning doit demander de l'argent à
Mussolini le dirigeant fasciste
italiening est alors recherché il a
besoin de plusieurs doses de morphine
par jour c'est un homme sans
avenir pendant toute une année les tent
de rencontrer
Mussolini
mais ce dernier n'a que faire du
Messager d'un leader dont le parti est
au plus bas en
Allemagne la mission de ging est un
échec il retourne en Suède dans la
famille de Karine un échec politique
marqué par son
addiction il touche le
fond le médecin d'un hôpital
psychiatrique le décrit comme suicidaire
dépressif égocentrique et détestant les
Juifs
[Musique]
en Allemagne Hitler libéré de prison
cherche à accéder au pouvoir par
d'autres
moyens ging est déterminé à li
aider il retourne en Allemagne en 1927
apparemment rétabli déterminé à
provoquer la chute de la République de
vaimmar au côté
d'Hitler l'atmosphère politique est
tendue la crise économique mondiale
entraîne un chômage de masse et suscite
des craintes pour
l'avenir les partisans d'Hitler et les
communistes s'affrontent dans les
rues Hitler désigne ging comme P
potentièire à Berlin car ce héros de
guerutement décoré a d'excellents
contact dans l'aristocratie et dans le
monde de la haute
finance en 1932 les nazis deviennent le
parti le plus puissant du rstack etingon
est le
Président si Hitler parvient au pouvoir
c'est est aussi grâce à son assistant
ging devenu ministre de l'Intérieur pour
la Prusse ging commence immédiatement à
réprimer ses opposants
politiques peu après le r stack brule
les causes de l'incendie reste inconnu
mais les conséquences sont
déterminantes les droits fondamentaux
sont suspendus la persécution devient
légale les commerces juifs sont
boycottés laiss attraque les communistes
et les socio-démocrates et des camps de
concentration sauvage commence à
apparaître le 11 avril
1933ing devient premier ministre de la
Prusse à cette fonction par la majorité
des représentants du peuple allemand et
en tant que candidat du plus puissant
parti je suis déterminé à exercer cette
fonction pour le plus grand bénéfice du
peuple
allemand
plus que tout je suis déterminé à rendre
à ce Parlement sa dignité d'entend comme
l'avait fait autrefois bismar un grand
chef
d'État fond la guestap la police secrète
et joue un rôle clé dans la mise en
place de la
dictature il ne tolère aucune
concurrence la commence à revendiquer le
pouvoir
ging et le commandant sler manigance
contre la direction des troupes du
parti ces photos ont été prises le 23
mai 1934 sur la lande de goldheim près
de
düseldorf ging commémore Albert
leoagetter un membre des troupes
paramilitaires de la résistance
allemande exécuté par les Français en
1923 un mois plus tard lors de la Nuit
des Longs couteau 200 personnes sont
assassin dont tous les membres éminents
de la SAA et leur chef
ernstum ging se retire dans sa maison à
obersalsberg non loin
d'Hitler la brutalité de ging suscite
l'admiration du dictateur qui le désigne
comme son successeur s'il venait à
mourir bonjour César tu viens me rendre
visite tu as pris ton repas
tu as bien
mangé allez
saute je nai pas de conscience Adol
Hitler ma
conscience l'assassinat de plus que
jamais à la réputation
deétranger des caricatur représent V
d'un tablier de bouch anglant une ha à
[Musique]
M image il veut s'engager dans la
politique étrangère et sait que sa
réputation rendra les choses
difficiles il veut être populaire adulé
par les foules comme ici en Autriche en
mai
[Musique]
1938 il laisse la guestapo et la police
aux mains de himler de Hedrich et
[Musique]
DSS ging commandant en second Hitler
veut jouir du pouvoir et jouer un rôle
de premier
plan Hitler met donc à sa disposition un
fond spécial et lui fait cadeau d'une
maison au frais de
l'État ce qui n'était d'abord qu'une
modeste cabane en rondin à la suédoise
devient carinal la splendide demeure de
SHF ces photos proviennent également des
possessions privées de ging les
diplomates et les chefs d'états
étrangers défi la
carinal
[Musique]
ging souffre toujours gravement de sa
toxicomanie son goût du déguisement et
de l'autoglorification semble vraiment
grotesque mais intérieurementin reste
fidèle à
lui-même il est interdit au
ressortissants allemands ou à leur
proches d'épouser des
Juifs
l'antisémitisme devient
loi les lois de Nurenberg sont annoncées
par gingl du congrès annuel du parti en
1935 l'une des hautes fonctions
accumulées par ging grevit une
importance particulière pour l'ancien
pilote celle de ministre de l'aviation
du Reich chargé de fonder une nouvelle
armée de
l'air en 193 5 lors du congrès du parti
ging présente l'armement qui a été
fabriqué secrètement au cours des
dernières
années le traité de Versailles est rompu
ouvertement sous les yeux du monde
entier à la fin de l'année ging dispose
de 1800
avions cette nouvelle force aérienne
jouera un rôle décisif dans la stratégie
d'Hitler son baptême du feu aura lieu en
1936 durant la guerre civile
espagnole ging remettant des médailles à
des soldats de la Légion Condor un
soldat filme la
cérémonie sous les yeux choqués du monde
l'Armée de l'Air fait ses preuves en
bombardant la ville espagnole de gernica
c'est ging qui ouvre la voie depuis le
nouveau ministère de l'aviation au
centre de Berlin celui qui exerce ici
son pouvoir joue également un rôle
central dans
l'économie en 1936 Gerling devient
responsable du plan de 4 ans et de ce
fait dictateur de l'économie et de
l'armement Hitler veut que l'économie
soit prête pour la guerre d'ici 4
ans c'est sa tâche la plus importante
jusqu'alors cette nouvelle mission
atteste de la confiance d'Hitler envers
son second car la guerre est sa priorité
absolue
importation matière première monnaie g
in contrôle presque tout et il a déjà un
œil sur le prochain
objectif Hitler ordonne l'annexion de
l'autricheing saisit l'occasion utilise
la menace pour faire pression sur le
gouvernement autrichien jusqu'à ce que
le chancelier schuchnik se retire
libérant ainsi la voix pour
Hitler
le 4 avril 1938 aurellius maer chef
forestier de carati filme l'arrivée
d'Hitler à
kagenft des images privées montrent le
retour d'Hitler mis en scène comme une
procession triomphale dans tout le
[Applaudissements]
pays l'annexion de l'Autriche est la
pogé de cette alliance entre Hitler
eting lorsque le dictateur exprime des
doutes ging les disciipe et
agit il se complète en temps de crise
dit Hitler ging fait preuve de
sangfroid le 15 mai 1938 ging retrouve
les décors de sa
jeunesse nationaliste de la vieille
école il voit ses rêves d'une Allemagne
grandi prendre vie avec l'annexion de
l'Autriche
à l'abri des caméras cependant les juifs
et les opposants politiques sont
humiliés dans la rue voire
arrêé ging se rend dans la région de
Salsbourg à mautendorf dans l'un des
châteaux de son enfance où il fête ses
retrouvailles avec ses sœurs Olga et
PAA tout deux sont mari à des avocats
Autrichiens ging voit dans l'annexion de
l'Autriche de grandes opportunités
commerciales la re vermaning l'un des
plus grands complexes industriels
d'Europe ne demande qu'à s'étendre au
sud-est et l'Autriche porte d'entrée des
Balcans est désormais sous contrôle
allemand ging est
satisfait tandis qu'il se plonge dans
ses souvenirs d'enfance Hitler prépare
la prochaine étape vers la
guerre il prévoit d'écraser la
Tchécoslovaquie et ging doit organiser
la mobilisation
économique mais il veut éviter une
grande guerre car il n'est pas sûr de la
[Musique]
remporter ging sait que les conditions
économiques et militaires ne sont pas
réunies mais il n'os pas le dire
ouvertement au contraire devant les
représentants de l'industrie
aéronautique il semble
confiant il y aura beaucoup de dégâts et
nous devrons entrer dans une grande
guerre ce qui ne m'ffrait
pas l'Allemagne sera alors la première
puissance mondiale elle contrôlera les
marchés mondiaux et sera un pays
riche mais nous devrons prendre des
risques déclare
[Musique]
ging il évite les conflits ouverts fait
tout ce que veut Hitler et pratique en
coulisse une diplomatie
[Musique]
Pacifique il reçoit à carinal des
diplomates hongrois polonais et
britanniqu
avant tout ging souhaite améliorer ses
relations avec
[Musique]
l'onre il voit l'Allemagne comme une
grande puissance impériale mais ne veut
pas d'une guerre
[Musique]
mondiale en septembre 1938 lors de la
conférence de Munich ging présente un
traité destiné à maintenir pour un
certain temps une paix fragile cela lui
vaudra d'être sévèrement critiqué par
Hitler en octobre 1938 les troupes
allemandes pénètrent la région des
sudettes comme prévu dans les accords de
minunque mais Hitler veut plus qu'une
guerre des fleurs comme il
l'appelle novembre 1938 baptême de la
fille de ging Ida à carinal à ses côtés
sa nouvelle épouse emis
sonomal les relations entre Hitler et
ging sont troublées pour la première
fois le dictateur le qualifie de
lâche mars 1939 tandis qu'itler marche
sur la tchéchoslovaquie ging passe ses
vacances en
Italie il a tout à coup perdu en
influence Hitler prend d'autres
conseillers dont Joakim Ribon trope aux
Affaires
étrangères ging sent que la guerre est
évitable mais il n'ose pas contredire
ouvertement chaque fois que je me tiens
devant le fureur dit-il mon cœur se sert
dans ma
poitrine ces images tirées des archives
privé de Girling ont été prises lors
d'un show aérien sur l'île
d'edon
ern toet responsable du renforcement de
l'aviation est complètement dépassé il
se suicidera en novembre
19 de nouveaux types d'avion sont
construiting sur Hitler que la VA fait
prête pour la
guerre au contrôle de l'économie et de
l'armement ging est le mieux placé pour
savoir si le Reich est réellement
capable de mener une grande
guerre mais il fait F des réalités et se
laisse impressionner par les 4000 avions
derniers et par les nombreuses escadries
de chasseurs
dépoussiérés en été 1939 ils sont 400000
à travailler pour la
Luft les quatre flottes aériennes
semblent parfaitement équipé pour une
grande
guerre l'épée mousé a été aiguisée au
cours des qu dernières années bien que
les bombes et le carburant manque par
rapport aux forces aériennes des autres
pays
le commandant en chef ging tente encore
d'empêcher la guerre
d'éclater le 6 juin 1939 à Berlin la
capitale est décorée pour accueillir la
Légion
Condor nous sommes à la veille de la
Seconde Guerre
mondiale Ginga plante presque Hitler C
son de jouer au
poker Hitler répond j'ai toujours joué
au
poker en Espagne 5000 soldats allemands
ont aidé Franco à accéder au pouvoir un
vol d'cès sans trop de
perte cette fois la menace prend une
dimension bien plus
terrible ging s'entretient secrètement
avec l'Angleterre il veut préserver la
paix et continuer à vivre dans le luxe
c'est la splendeur comme un homme de la
Renaissance il a beaucoup à
[Musique]
perdre l'attaque contre la Pologne
commence le 1er septembre
1939 la l vaffo de ging prend le
contrôle des cieux presque sans effort
les Polonais n'ont aucune chance des
bombardiers ont piqués aux sirènes
stridantes ouvrent la voie aux forces
terrestres
[Musique]
g in loyal à Hitler car il lui doit
tout des films privés le montr à
l'ouverture du secours d'hiver en
octobre
1939 ces tentativ Tim d'influen hit ne
donne
riening reste docile c'est lui qui donne
l'ordre d'expulser tous les juifs
polonais l'occupant allemand a créé des
G comme ici l'actuelle Lodge où les
Juifs vivent dans des conditions
sordides bientôt les ghetos ne sont plus
que des étapes précédant la déportation
vers les camps
d'extermination ging joue aussi un rôle
dans cette
guerre en novembre 1938 alors que les
synagogues brûlent ging décrète que la
population juive d'Allemagne devra payer
un milliard de Reichmark en guise
d'expiation selon
lui
les Juifs seront dépossédés et
contraints à
l'exil cependant ging veille
soigneusement à ce que son nom ne soit
pas associé à ces
crimes lors de la campagne de France
Laalou montre de net signe de
faiblesse le corps expéditionnaire
britannique se replie à Ker sur la côte
de la
Manche ging promet que ses avions
détruiront les troupes alliés mais les
choses se passent
différemment 338000 soldats anglais
français et belge parviennent à
s'enfuir si ging avait pu tenir parole
l'Angleterre aurait eu peu de chance
d'empêcher une invasion
allemande
de semaines auparavant Rotterdam avait
été gravement touché par la
N alors que des négociations avaient
lieu pour la rédition des Pays-Bas les
avions de ging avaient rasé la ville
sans
défense le commandement allemand avait
été informé trop tard des
négociations la campagne sur le front de
l'Ouest s'est achevé assez rapidement
Hitler commandant suprême victorieux le
bâton de maréchal
sgering fait un peu mieux un titre est
créé spécialement pour lui maréchal du
Reich il est le plus haut gradé de
l'armée allemande et possède une
résidence kinal qui gagne peu à peu en
splendeur un manoir rempli de trésors
artistiques du monde
[Musique]
entier ging collectionne les vieilles
toiles de maîre les tapisserie les
sculptures et rien ne l'arrête lorsqu'il
convoite un
[Musique]
objet il voit dans la défaite de la
France une parfaite occasion de
[Musique]
plier Paris regorge d'œuvre d'art et le
commandant en second de l'État vient
prendre tout ce qu'il
désire le Louvre lieu sacré pour tout
amateur né pour ging qu'un grand magasin
en libre
service sur sa liste de courses de grand
noms comme Rubin véasquez kranach le
jeune crranache
[Musique]
l'ancien peu lui importe que de nombreux
tableaux est appartenu à des Juifs peu
de temps
auparavant gingle collectionneur ne
négocie pas dans la plupart des cas
c'est lui seul qui fixe les
prix il charge ensuite ses achats dans
un train spécial qui les achemine vers
carinal il y a presque une addiction
dans cette collection qui remplit son
musée herering comme un monument à sa
propre
[Musique]
gloire des experts ratissent les pays
occupés à la cherche d'œuvre d'art pour
la collection de
ging tout propriétaire qui refuse de
coopérer risque sa
vie après la campagne du front de
l'Ouest Nalou va compte des bases au
Pays-Bas en Belgique et dans le Nord de
la France les îles britanniques sont
àorté
demain Hitler veut envahir l'Angleterre
et la l de girlling doit prendre le
contrôle de l'espace aérien et bombarder
l'île
gling pense que ces avions peuvent
détruire la Royal Air Force en 5
semaines visite d'une base aérienne en
France lors de l'été 1940 avec Bruno
lurur ancien camarade de la Grande
Guerre et général de l'aviation à gauche
de
ging ils se connaissent depuis septembre
1914 les récits de batailles aériennes
de leurur avait alors poussé ging vers
la LFT
vaff en 1940 giring déclare que leursur
est son général le plus
fénéant mais il le laisse tranquille car
comme il dit j'ai besoin de quelqu'un
pour boire une bouteille de rouge avec
moi le
[Musique]
soir la bataille d'Angleterre sera sa
première grande défaite
la Royal Air Force est légale de la
l les speed fire anglaislig de
per fin septembre 1940 les plans
d'invasion sont temporairement mis de
[Musique]
côté le commandant en chef de La l va se
retire de la scène publique
d'octobre 1940 à janvier 1941 ging est
en vacances sur les lacs de
carinal même au pinacle de la lutte
aérienne il ne renonce pas à aller
chasser en Prusse orientale car
ent-temps il est devenu Reich
siermeister le chef de la chasse du
Reich les erreurs de structure et de
planification dans la loft va sont
flagrantes mais ing accuse les
autres il se trouve au milieu d'une
guerre qu'il n'a pas voulu mais qu'il
mène quand même avec toutes ses
conséquences le 22 juin 1941 avec
l'attaque sur l'Union soviétique la
guerre d'anéantissement exigée par
Hitler
commence ging est bien au courant des
exécutions de civiles derrière la ligne
de
front au printemps 1941 il charge
reinardidrich chef de la sécurité du
Reich d'établir une série de directives
destinées aux troupes désignant les
personnes à fusiller principalement des
responsables politiques et des
Juifs des millions de prisonniers
soviétiques perd la vie dans cette
guerre
à Berlin la capitale ging en tant que
second Hitler dispose d'un pouvoir
presque absolu en juillet 1941 la
victoire sur l'Union soviétique semble
apporter de
maain ging accorde plus de pouvoirs à
reinardidrich Don les troupes spéciales
tuent des milliers de personnes par jour
sur le front de
l'Est chargeidrich de mettre en place la
solution finale de la question juive
dans les zones d'influence allemande
d'Europe partout en Allemagne les
déportations
commencent ces enregistrements privés
montrent les 293 derniers juif de drest
embarqué dans un train au début du mois
de mars
1942 il se dirige vers la rampe du camp
d'extermination d'Auschwitz
birkeno
seul 10 d'entre eux auraient
survécu la signature de ging est un pas
de plus vers le meurtre
organisé mais officiellement il ne veut
rien avoir à faire avec ces
crimes
la lou va n'est pas préparée à cette
guerre son système de défense est
chaotique même l'ingénieur willly
Schmith ne peut résoudre le problème
principal il n'y a pas assez d'avion ni
de moteur assez
puissant outre les soldats ces planeurs
transportent du matériel militaire léger
et ils ont j un rôle important dans la
bataille de
[Musique]
crête les nouveaux progrès technologique
arrivent trop tard ou ne sont d'aucune
utilitén est responsable du désastre de
la défense il s'effondre sous le poids
des responsabilités et met fin à ses
jour des décisions préliminaires sont
prises sur le front de
l'Est l'attaque sur
moscouchou
une armée entière tombe à
Stalingrad ging avait promis de livrer
500 tonnes de matériel chaque jour par
les
air les troupes encerclés n'en reçoivent
qu'une
[Musique]
fraction ses relations avec Hitler sont
au plus
bas nuit après nuit les villes
allemandes subissent les attaques
dévastatrices des bombardiers
anglais si un avion ennemi atteint le
Reich j'en mangerai mon chapeau
diging sal lou va est
impuissante les unités antiaériennne ne
peuvent qu'endiguer le flux des
bombardiers pas
l'arrêter ging est aussi responsable de
la défense anti-aérienne il est aux
commande de la ligue de protection
aérienne du Reich et de ses millions de
membres
enregistrement privé de mars
1943 des unités de défense antiaérienne
effectuent un exercice d'urgence dans le
centre de
Berlin leur plus grand souci concerne
les attaques au
gaz les jeunes et les adultes portent le
masque à gaz du
peuple il pensent être bien équipé pour
faire face aux attaques à venir c'est
sans compter sur la puissance
dévastatrice des explosifs brisants et
des bombes
incendiaires
comme à Hambourg en juillet
1943 une tempête de feu dans les rues
qui détruit une grande partie de la
ville en
céatique les températures atteignent les
degr plus de 40000 personnes
meurent comment King réagira-t-il à
cette
catastrophe il semble imperturbable
léthargique il ne prend aucune décision
il distribue des médailles tout au
plus
salouft vaff ne peut arrêter les
attaques des
[Musique]
alliés les innovations techniques comme
les radars aéroportés ou les se lenstein
profitent à terme au forces
aériennes mais les Anglais parviennent à
déjouer leurs attaques en aveuglant les
radars avec du papier
d'aluminium ce fut un facteur crucial
dans l'attaque de
[Musique]
Hambourg les attaques visent également
la population civile afin de démoraliser
celle-ci
[Musique]
l'Allemagne sous les
bombes des images non censurées jamais
montré dans la presse filmée de
[Musique]
l'époque la suprématie aérienne sur le
front de l'Est est perd depuis longtemps
tandis queing reçoit à carinal et montre
ses dernières acquisitions
artistiques le commandant en chef ne
veut pas voir ce genre d'image il s'est
éloigné de ces
[Musique]
troupes la chasse l'intéresse plus que
tout
et sur sa caméra il enregistre ce qui
lui importe plus que les lourdes pertes
parmi ses pilotes ou les villes qui
tombent dessert sur son terrain de
chasse
[Musique]
privée
depuis le printemps 1944 l'aviation
américaine contrôle l'espace aérien
allemand les chasseurs de ging ne
peuvent presque rien contre cette force
supérieure il manque de tout de moteur
d'essence de pilote et surtout de
décision clair de leur
supérieur les bombardements sont plus
destructeurs que jamais
jusqu'alors le bergov d'Hitler est resté
intact le chef de guerre est outré par
l'échec de la L et par les ve promesse
de son successeur
désigné en mai 1944 les forces
américaines bombarde l'industrie
[Musique]
pétrolière le pilier de l'industrie de
guerre allemande est
brisée
les voies de transport sont
systématiquement
détruites lorsque les Alliés débarquent
en Normandie le 6 juin 1944 laemande est
impuissante
[Musique]
elle a été
vaincue l'ampleur des pertes est
catastrophique
rien qu'en novembre 1944 404 avions de
chasse sont perdus et 244 pilotes
[Musique]
tués une sorte d'arme miracle pourrait
faire tourner le
vent le seul et unique espoir de dominer
les cieux à nouveau réside dans le G
réaction
m262 1400 de ces chasseurs sont livrés à
l'armée de l'IR mais plus de 200
resteront au
sol mais même une armada de jet n'aurait
pas suffi face à la puissance supérieure
d'une flotte de
Bombardier adolp Gallant général de la
luftoif est connu pour son Fran
parler à plusieurs reprises il soulligne
la désolente infériorité des armes
allemandes
maisging ne tolère aucune critique
galant tombe en
disgrce il deviendra le Bou émissaire
responsable de l'effondrement de la
LFT fin janvier le général de la l va
remplacer la lutte pour l'espace aérien
allemand
s'achève les pilotes allemands toujours
plus jeunes et moins entraînés font des
missions
suicides
à la fin de la guerre ging se retire à
ber de
SCAD à Berlin l'Armée Rouge se ferait un
chemin vers le bunker d'Hitler au centre
de la
ville dans un message radio ging annonce
qu'il prendra la tête du gouvernement si
Hitler ne donne pas signe de
vie le commandant en second pense que
l'URE de la succession a
sonné mais à Berlin Hitler sans venir la
trahison et ordonne au SS d'arrêter gin
chez
lui il est démis de toutes ses
fonctions alors que l'armée américaine
s'approche d'obersalsberg les S mèingorf
en Autriche dans l'un des châteaux de
son
enfance suite au suicide d'Hitler il
prévoit de négocier avec le général
américainenower il croit toujours qu'il
ne peut pas être
négligé le 7 mai 1945 Herman ging se
constitue volontairement prisonnier
américain croyant à tort que les
vainqueurs négocieront avec lui en tant
qu'émissaire
allemand surpris les soldats s'emparent
des armes des médailles et de la bague
en émeraude de l'ancien maréchal
Emy sa
femme fill sont faites prisonnières par
les soldats
américains même prisonnier ging reste
imuablement confiant il tient une
conférence de presse se reconnaîtra-t-il
coupable je ne savais rien de ce qui se
passait dans les camps de concentration
diging c'est l'œuvre de himle
en tant que maréchal du Reich il
n'aurait jamais permis de telles
atrocités pas une trace de
remord tous les membres de la l de ging
sont désormais prisonniers de
guerre adolp Gallant bavardant avec les
pilotes américains le maréchal kel rink
récemment encore commandant en chef sur
le front de
l'Ouest R qui a fait 2350 sorties plus
qu'aucun autre pilote
allemand Herman ging semble en effet
surpris de figurer sur la liste des
criminels de
guerre un journaliste américain qui
couvre la conférence de presse de
ging ce grand homme semblait plutôt mal
à l'aise en sur il demande au
traducteurs de préciser qu'à cause d'une
querelle lui le maréchal du Reich
n'échangeait plus avec
depuemp complètement in communicne-il en
agitant le Doig veuz insister sur ce
point c'est important ail
[Musique]
dit le plus haut gradé des naz encore
vivant comparé à
NBER dans cette ville où se ten les
congrès du parti désormais dévasté par
les bombardements les principaux
criminels de guerre sont jugés par un
tribunal allié
[Musique]
nurberg a été ciblé par les attaques
aériennes ce n'est plus qu'un champ de
[Musique]
rine mais le seul bâtiment qui en a
réchappé le tribunal où se sont déroulés
les procès des plus grands criminels de
guerre les prisonniers attendent dans
ses
cellules l'homme que les alliés appelle
le nazi numéro 1 et lui aussi surveillé
jour et
nuit gering qui récemment encore avalait
des dizaines de pilules n'en prend plus
et suit un
régime le 25 novembre 1945 ging entre
dans la salle
d'audience pour la première fois de
l'histoire des hommes politiques et des
militaires doivent répondre de leur CRIM
devant un tribunal
les T que nous cherchons à condamner et
punir ont ét si calculé si pernicieux et
si dévastateur que la civilisation ne
peut tolérer qu'il soit ignoré parce
qu'elle ne peut
survivre peine de
il n'éprouve aucun
remord celui qui égal presque hit en
puissance prantavoir rien su de ces
millions de
crimes je n'ai jamais été d'accord avec
l'idée qu'une race puisse être
considérée comme la race dominante sur
toutes les
autres contraire j'ai toujours souligné
les différences entre les
races lors du contreinterrogatoire le
procureur général américain Robert
Jackson tente de coincer l'accusé mais
avec ging ça ne mène nulle
part c'est exact n'est-ce pas je vous ai
déjà répondu très clairement mais ces
explications font partie de ce qui a
déjà été
dit votre avocat y
veillera verbe est s de lui une dernière
fois la cerie et accuse les Alliés
d'avoir commis les mêmes crimes que les
nazis son but est de laisser une image
positive de lui-même dans la
postérité mais le poids des preuves est
accablant les procureurs soviétiques
montrent un film qui dissipe tous les
doutes
achitz
le plus effroyable des crimes contre
l'humanité c'estging
entre autres qui en est
responsable
il est reconnu coupable de tous les
chefs d'accusation et condamné à
mort jusqu'à la fin il ne manifeste
aucun
remord mais toutes ces choses étai
nécessaires si j'ai bien compris pour
protéger oui oui c'était nécessaire dans
la situation nous nous
trouvions le jugement ne m'a nullement
affecté déclareingo psychologue
judiciaire
américain l'exécution est prévu pour le
16 octobre
1946 dans un dernier coup d'éclat il
écrit une lettre au gardien de
prison lorsqu'il a été conduit en prison
il avait en sa possession TR capsules de
poison j'ai mis la première dans mes
habits pour qu'on la trouve en me
fouillant
la seconde était si bien cachée dans ma
cellule qu'elle n'a pas été trouvée
malgré des fouilles fréquentes et
minutieuses je l'avais sur moi dans mes
bottes lors des
audiences la trè capsule était dans ma
petite trousse de toilette dans unon de
crème de so elle était tout à fait
impossible à
trouversule de poison caché l'ultime
secret de
un autre secret est découvert à
berchesgaden peu après la fin de la
guerre les troupes américaines trouvent
la maison de campagne de ging non loin
des ruines du bergov
d'Hitler
[Musique]
le guide de montagne de ging fraternise
avec un soldat et lui donne en souvenir
des pellicules venant de la propriété de
ging
elles ont croupi des années dans une
cave aux États-Unis avant d'être
retrouvé et soigneusement
restauré
les films privés de ging montrent des
scènes clés de la vie du plus puissant
homme dans la dictature nazi après
[Musique]
Hitler le plus proche confident
d'Hitler le visage jovial du
régime
un homme au multiples
visages il fait dynamiter carinal son
imposante demeure située près de Berlin
vers la fin de la
guerre avant cela les uvres d'art sont
mises en sécurité puis confisqué par
l'armée
américaine les troupes de déblément
tentent d'effacer l'histoire mais il en
restera toujours
[Musique]
trace